[Music]
on this Friday night please for reform
and a remedy the pressure piling on
Canada's Health Care System people are
gradually losing faith in how we can
provide these critical type services and
how heartbroken families are trying to
trigger improvements the federal
conservative leader on air travel the
airlines think they can get away with
mistreating us and the rising cost of
living our wide-ranging interview with
Pierre polieva wear twisters in January
look at a tornado the deadly and
destructive storms striking the southern
U.S
plus morning a member of rock and roll
royalty the turbulent life of Lisa Marie
Presley
global national with Fara Nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us waiting in an emergency room is an
excruciating experience for anyone but
waiting for care while you're dying is
unimaginable this week we learned of two
separate cases where Nova Scotia women
died after sitting in the ER for more
than six hours one a mother of three the
other a grandmother showing us the human
cost if an HR crisis in hospital ERS and
shaking the trust of Canadians in our
top story tonight Ross Lord speaks to a
family member trying a new tactic to
force accountability and change in our
health care System
Charlene snow was known for her great
sense of humor and her compassion she
spent Christmas fighting through
flu-like symptoms lasting more than a
week before finally agreeing to go to a
crowded Cape Breton emergency department
after approximately I'd say seven hours
she had a chat with some staff members
and asked you know realistically when
would I see a doctor and they they said
likely it won't be until tomorrow
morning Charlene decided to leave
planning to attend an urgent care clinic
on December 31st but she didn't make it
to the next morning
um Freddy picked her up and they went
home and she died within the hour
doctors say her death was caused by a
buildup of fluid on her heart hers is
the second Nova Scotia family in a week
to go public mother of three Allison
holthoff died in a hospital ER in the
town of Amherst her husband says she
also waited for seven hours not
receiving the care she needed until it
was too late it was getting worse she
wasn't doing good
she was in pain and uh
there was not much of a response as
we're doing what we can we don't have
any beds they're the latest victims of a
chronic shortage of nurses doctors and
hospital beds at a time when more
patients need care The Tipping Point
accelerated since the start of the
covid-19 pandemic but it's really
reached the level of Crisis um the the
problems that we're seeing are not just
happening once in a while it's now it's
a it's a daily event in a letter to all
Health ministers in Canada the
association of Emergency Physicians says
our health system needs immediate
interventions to ensure its survival the
emergency doctors blame politics and
bureaucracies saying by failing to
protect emergency department resources
for patients we're contributing to
multiple avoidable deaths across the
country daily what's happening is people
are gradually losing faith and how we
can provide these critical type Services
they're losing their faith one patient
at a time to force accountability
Charlene Snow's family he has
established a website to collect other
Healthcare horror stories from patients
families and from Front Line workers it
has been totally overwhelming it has
been heartwarming it has been touching
I've cried so many times reading
people's stories and I just I can't
I just can't believe that it's happened
to so many other people in a statement
the federal health Ministry expressed
condolences for the Nova Scotia deaths
and says it's ready to collaborate with
provinces and territories to improve
health services for all Canadians Nova
scotia's Progressive conservatives swept
to power on a promise to fix health care
more than a year later the Grim reality
is forcing Premier Tim Houston to soften
his language we knew that the challenge
would be significant it is significant
so we're focused on it to some there's
been a shift from how to improve health
care to how to keep it from collapsing
Ross Lord Global News
it's been a little more than four months
since Pierre pauliev took the reins of
Canada's Federal conservative party and
since then the new Tory leader has not
made it a habit of speaking regularly
with large media Outlets but today
pauliev did agree to an interview with
global news after delivering a speech at
Winnipeg's Frontier Center for Public
Policy Melissa region conducted that
interview and she joins us Melissa what
stood out to you in your conversation
with polyev well as you said it was a
crowd at Frontier Center for Public
Policy lunch here 500 people were there
lots of people you know you would think
would be preaching to the base it's a
right-wing think tank but not everybody
in the crowd was of that ilk necessarily
I think that there was a lot of people
in there just looking to have
conversations and here's something new
about that sort of voices what the
frustration that a lot of people are
feeling across this country air travel
that chaos that had come up of course uh
he not surprisingly placed the blame at
the foot of the federal liberals saying
that they are in charge they regulate
this industry in any chaos that ensues
is their fault
we have very little competition and
that's why the airlines think they can
get away with mistreating US airlines
are federal responsibility they're
federally regulated airports are
federally mandated and under Justin
Trudeau are Airlines and our airports
have been a disaster an absolute
disaster
Melissa pauliev and the conservatives
have been channeling a lot of
frustrations that that Canadians are
feeling right now so what did he tell
you about those concerns
well you listed a Litany of frustrations
that he's heard as he's you know talking
to Canadians the same as the liberal
government makes their way across
talking to Canadians and they would have
their take or their take of what
Canadians are feeling would certainly be
different than what Mr uh pauliev is
saying that he is felt but something
that has come up not surprisingly the
cost of living that's something that
we're all feeling the pinch of he said
that that uh is you kind of found the
Flames I guess you could say that that's
only going to get worse which is what a
lot of people fear the Liberals and NDP
want a triple triple triple the carbon
tax on your heat your gas your groceries
that's going to crush families I won't
allow it I'm going to get rid of the
carbon tax and fight climate change with
technology not taxes
so there's a lot more that he had say we
take a lot of uh topics from
reconciliation to how to address climate
change on the path uh forward from you
know this pinch that we're all feeling
how long is it going to last what are
the fixes so there was a lot more to
this interview that we will share with
you Melissa Richard and Winnipeg thank
you Melissa
today is an important day for indigenous
survivors traumatized by Canada's Indian
Day School System the deadline to apply
to be part of a class action lawsuit to
be compensated for the years of abuse
they suffered in those institutions is
set at midnight tonight as Nita Garcia
explains it's a task far easier said
than done for many victims as they're
forced to visit their agonizing
experiences once again
that's my dad he was the chief of
skedants Andy Wilson is sitting in front
of a framed photo of his father who
along with his mother survived
residential school Wilson was in
kindergarten when he went to a similar
but less talked about institution of
assimilation known as Indian Day School
it was
just as dramatic as the residential
schools like many he grew up struggling
to cope with the trauma from the abuse
he suffered there and later grappled
with alcoholism I still see a lot of
people suffering Canada signed a 1.47
billion dollar settlement with survivors
of the more than 600-day schools that
operated across Canada between 1863 and
2000. midnight Friday is the deadline to
apply but in order to determine
compensation between ten thousand and
two hundred thousand dollars the
paperwork requires victims to detail
their abuse thank you
Wilson who was compensated last year
says it was like reliving the trauma I
had to do it three times
and I had to do it with my wife who
helped me get through so many people in
this country look at it as adults that
are applying
but they don't seem to remember
that these were kids when they were
being raped they were being beaten
sexually abused in these schools over
178 thousand claims have been filed
since the start of the process three
years ago more than one thousand during
the six-month extension period after
July 13 2022 of those about 70 percent
have been paid in a statement the
federal Crown indigenous relations
Ministry said in part compensation and
deadlines were negotiated by the parties
and approved by the courts Canada cannot
unilaterally amend the claims period
deadline the model
of the Indian Act and how it was used to
develop apartheid system in South Africa
you can really see
what the whole Colonial agenda was for
the last 150 200 years they're calling
for a complete removal of the deadline
resources to support survivors who apply
as well as better understanding from the
public about the day school experience
and the lasting effects of it
Global News
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress as
a result of their experience you can
call toll free and speak in confidence
at 1-800-721-0066
get ready for more potential delays and
disruptions at Canadian airports in
Eastern Canada severe weather is
blanketing large parts of the region
today the best piece of advice would be
to stay home if you can work from home
that would be perfect a winter storm
closed several schools have led to
travel chaos in some parts of Southern
Quebec today wintry weather warnings
also stretched into parts of Ottawa and
the GTA with more snow expected in some
parts of Eastern Canada overnight in
Atlanta Canada a mix of snow and
freezing rain also shut down schools in
New Brunswick and Pei while rainfall and
possibly damaging wind warnings are in
effect for parts of Nova Scotia and
Newfoundland and Labrador
[Music]
thank you
a terrifying close call in the southern
U.S after a major storm system slammed
the region on Thursday and spawned
reports of at least 35 tornadoes across
several States at least nine people were
killed in the severe weather Alabama's
historic city of Selma wasn't spared
from the devastation after a large
tornado ripped through the key symbol of
the 1960s American Civil Rights Movement
Jackson crossco looks at the damage
after this latest weather event
endangering Americans
oh my god with little warning a rare
mid-January Tornado Outbreak pummeled
The American South you could hear the
rule uh glass going everywhere you could
hear the roof not only been going off
right over our head the storms cut a
wide swath across multiple States one of
the Twisters stayed on the ground for
nearly 80 kilometers and this lay on my
front door so hard
historic Selma Alabama took the brunt of
it buildings crumpled homes flattened
this was my mom house and in the
aftermath of fires raged out of control
they tore of the chimney
built the car
I mean it's it's bad down here like
Louisiana it's bad in Georgia at least
two people were killed including a
five-year-old boy crushed by a falling
tree we know we've had multiple
tornadoes across the state uh the damage
is you know literally Statewide in
different places across the U.S 2023 is
off to a brutal start in flood ravaged
California they're only now getting a
full picture of the damage from weeks of
back-to-back storms that have
overwhelmed the state with heavy rain
right now Statewide precipitation is 153
percent of average for the water here
today more torrential rain and dangerous
winds are expected this weekend leading
to more warnings about flooding and
mudslides back in Alabama thousands are
still without power just as temperatures
take a brutal plunge the storms Left
Behind millions of dollars in damage and
the promise of weeks of recover
Jackson prosco Global News
former U.S president Donald Trump's
family Empire has been ordered to pay
1.6 million dollars for evading taxes
for years it's the maximum fine allowed
two companies affiliated with the trunk
or organization were convicted last
month on 17 charges including criminal
tax fraud and falsifying business
records the charges were based on a
scheme in which Executives were paid in
gifts like luxury cars and private
school tuition and it was all kept off
the books nobody's expected to go to
jail and there is no risk if the Trump
real estate business going under but
this is the first ever criminal
conviction of one of Trump's companies
there are new details tonight about the
blast that rocked in Ontario City
coming up the tragic outcome of this
early morning explosion
in Ontario the man critically injured in
a series of explosions at a hazardous
waste facility yesterday has died police
say they're not releasing his identity
because his family is still being
notified the man was in his 30s and was
the Lone worker at the facility in Saint
Catharines when the explosions happened
he was transferred to hospital with
serious Burns crews are working to
secure the scene before an investigation
can begin it's expected to take seven to
ten days to pinpoint the cause
and at least three people are still
missing following a fire explosion at a
propane Factory in Quebec
it happened Thursday morning in San Rock
de la chagan about 50 kilometers north
of Montreal after searching the scene
last night police said today they can't
be sure there are only three victims the
investigation could take days due to
dangerous materials on site and their
search efforts are now being hampered by
a snowstorm the cause of the explosion
is still unclear but police don't
believe it's suspicious or criminal in
nature
[Music]
I had the claims that could mean a major
victory for Russia in Ukraine
[Music]
a surgeon in Ukraine likely took a few
extra deep breaths before removing a
live grenade stuck in a soldier's chest
the grenade was lodged right beneath his
heart it was about four centimeters long
the surgery had to be performed without
a commonly used technique that controls
bleeding with electricity the soldier is
now recovering
Ukraine is denying Russian claims that
its troops have captured the key salt
mining town of solidar if true it is the
first Battlefield victory for the
Kremlin in months it would also give
Russia a new staging point for the
bigger battle over the entire donbass
region in the east as Crystal gemancing
Reports it's also the second time this
week Russians have made the Bold claim
Ukrainian border guards shared multiple
videos of battles in and around solidar
a move to demonstrate the fighting is
ongoing Global News cannot independently
verify when these images were recorded
or the exact locations
Russia's defense Ministry spokesperson
announced Friday its regular forces took
the town saying full control allows
Russia to cut off Ukrainian supplies and
soldiers going to back moot but on
Wednesday the private Russian mercenary
group Wagner said its soldiers had
captured Solitaire highlighting
potential divisions within Russian ranks
Ukraine says all of the claims are
untrue that solidair has not Fallen
while addressing Lithuanian lawmakers
Vladimir zolenski said the aggressor
must be defeated on Ukrainian land so
that we don't have to fight on the land
of other European peoples
hot use how battles have been described
in solidarity just like in nearby back
moot which has seen some of the most
intense and deadly fighting
there are still hundreds of residents in
solidar most have spent their days
hidden away in the few buildings left
standing if Russia's claim is true it
would be the first victory for the
Kremlin since July
Ukraine aided by Western weapons
launched Swift counter offenses and
drove out invading forces from nearly
all of harkiv oblast and her son that
city was liberated in November but that
hasn't stopped Russian missile strikes
much of what's happening in the East is
shared by officials or those linked to
Ukrainian volunteer groups to social
media some of which show jaw-dropping
battles in this nearly year-long War
Crystal commencing Global News London
[Music]
a life in the spotlights but filled with
Warriors
[Music]
she was famous from the day she was born
the only child of Elvis Presley Lisa
Marie Presley died last night at just 54
years old according to reports she had
gone into cardiac arrest as Mike
Armstrong explains hers was a life-lived
weathering multiple tragedies to the
point Presley herself said she was lucky
she made it as far as she did
it was clear something was wrong Lisa
Marie Presley at the Golden Globes
Tuesday appeared somewhat out of sorts
in this interview I just wrote a photo
of him oh and another she leaned on her
date for support yeah I'm gonna grab
your arm yes
um Presley it hasn't been seen much in
recent months there were interviews to
promote the movie about her father's
life but since losing her son to suicide
in 2020 she's been reclusive living in
what she's called grief's unrelenting
grip Presley did appear at Graceland
last week for what would have been
Elvis's 88th birthday she told the fans
in attendance they were the reason she
was there I keep saying you're the only
people that can bring me out
of my life
Presley was pronounced dead in hospital
according to reports she was found at
home unconscious by her housekeeper her
mother Priscilla issued a statement
saying the family is quote shocked and
devastated by the tragic death of their
beloved Lisa Marie Presley was born in
1968 the daughter of the king of rock
and roll she was the most famous baby in
the world at the time her parents would
divorce when she was just four when
Elvis died in 1977 Lisa Marie was nine
she was at Graceland that morning and
lived through days of what she called
pandemonium
Presley followed in her Father's
Footsteps she released three albums it
would have been easier she said not to
go into the family business of music but
she didn't have a choice you know
naturally that's just where my heart is
where my interest is so and I feel it's
important in the world so I do it
Presley was married four times including
to another singer Michael Jackson and
actor Nicholas Cage she leaves behind
three daughters one an accomplished
actress Riley Keough it was a life with
bitter divorces a battle with a business
manager that left her millions in debt
and struggles with addiction but she's
being remembered as someone who
persevered Presley would say she
inherited her father's strength and
rebelliousness
she missed out on she said was the
protection of a father
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is a Covey
of quail an Oso used British Columbia
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]